biden's weakness on the world stage is
reaching all corners of the globe
tonight the world is feeling this as
saudi arabia reportedly considering
accepting chinese currency instead of
our u.s dollar for chinese oil sales the
current conversion rate is 16 cents for
every one dollar of chinese currency the
saudis they reportedly won't even talk
take joe's calls at this point they're
so angry at him and this deal that is
pending with iran british prime minister
boris johnson he's begging saudi arabia
he's headed there to meet with the crown
prince to beg the saudis and opec
nations to increase oil production here
with reaction former u.s secretary
energy secretary and governor of the
great state of texas
rick perry
the estimates you gave me
are on the low side we have
probably 200 years worth of natural gas
if we open up anwar and
we're talking about only known
resources in terms of oil we got a
hundred years worth of that
uh why would why did joe biden really
give in on energy independence and how
dangerous and how dumb as
this decision turned out to be
sean um your program has done a really
good job of
exposing this administration for just
the
either
total ignorance or the complete
capitulation of america's energy
power
as you clearly stated here we've got an
enormous amount of energy at our
disposal
the idea that we were as our country
led by our president
going to venezuela
going to iran going to countries that
hate us and asking them to increase
their production
wasn't lost on
the saudis
they watch that
they see a president who attacks the
natural resources in their country and
then they see this president go and deal
with the iranians this is a country that
hates saudi arabia that is in direct
conflict with them every day that
attacked them while i was the secretary
of energy at one of their refineries
and
you expect them to take your phone call
mr president
uh
this is a a stunning lack of either
political uh acumen uh which i don't
believe it is i just think
yeah he he really
dislikes
the oil and gas industry so much that
he's willing to jeopardize not just our
future but the future of our allies
around the world it is unconscionable
now the premier of alberta said that the
keystone xl pipeline of joe didn't
cancel it would have been complete he
said that that would have meant 900 000
barrels of canadian oil would be flowing
into the us every day
canada has also said
by using the means we have available now
they can give us 400 000 extra barrels
of oil a day
why why isn't there any
any urgency
to take them up on their offer get back
to energy independence it's not even on
the table
i don't have an answer for that do you
this message from the biden
administration to the rest of the world
but particularly to the woke left
that i'm going to
do what you demand me to do and that is
to bring the oil and gas industry to its
knees
that message is being heard loud and
clear from the board rooms across
america to the federal reserve
all across this country every agency of
government they have their esg their
environmental
concepts of which they're pushing into
all of their regulations and it's not
lost on our oil and gas producers it's
not lost on our allies around the world
this administration truly is willing to
put the world in jeopardy
to send a message to his buddies in the
political side of things that he's going
to hole firm for them on this climate
change issue hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else